au moins que Basile Boli qui a été un
joueur qui a 23 ans a gagné la
Gambardella sur une fausse identité qui
ne puisse pas me donner des leçons de
morale à la limite je viens prendre le
son de morale je pensais pas te parfait
mais pas de Basile bolide
bonsoir voilà ce que j'aime dans cette
émission là c'est Carole en cours
Michel Bernier Richard Cocciante voilà
c'est Thierry Ardisson non
je viens de la suivre je crois que vous
regardez pour la fin d'habitude je suis
pas timide là sincèrement je suis un peu
intimide
s'entraîneur de l'OM oui l'OM c'est le
plus gros budget de l'Hexagone 1 2 3
plus gros 330 millions de francs par an
c'est beaucoup plus que calé par exemple
alors l'OM visait le titre de champion
de France en début de saison ils
finissent 15e avec 330 millions de
francs je vous laisse faire le calcul
chez vous
alors
l'OM a sauvé sa tête enfin reste en D1
grâce ce qu'on appelait de mon temps le
goal averade et qui s'appelle maintenant
la meilleure différence de but
c'était du franglais
donc l'OM voilà non sinon l'OM oui alors
vous bah vous avez refusé
la conférence de presse qui était prévue
le samedi dernier vous avez parlé vous
avez parlé à François et vous parlez à
tout moment en parle et je vous en
remercie et on va mettre un petit
chanson pour fêter ça
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et voilà les Marseillais Charlie alors
si le club était passé en D2 vous dites
on m'aurait jeté dans le vieux port
bah oui parce que bon je crois que tout
a une fin malheureusement ça se termine
avec un changement d'entraîneur qui est
un peu une tradition dans le métier je
pensais que la parenthèse était fermée
et puis au fur et à mesure que les
semaines avancées je me sentais sur le
plan médiatique toujours autant
responsable donc je me disais bon il
fallait quand même que ça se terminait à
la fin qui descende pas parce que je
crois que je serai responsable de cette
naissance
le Titanic c'est pas vous non non il y a
encore que je regardais si dans la poche
et j'ai pas une vrille comme j'ai pas eu
bon le foot français ça va pas fort faut
dire les choses Roland il faut être
clair bah disons que ça va pas fort ça
va pas fort par rapport au grand pays
qui sont
Gueugnon petit club qui a gagné la Coupe
de la Ligue face au PSG les clubs
professionnels français à
l'international ils sont juste zéro quoi
Marseille - Bordeaux-Lyon Monaco ils ont
été balayés de la Coupe d'Europe non
mais justement on a Thierry c'est que si
vous présentez un début d'émission le
budget de Marseille qui est de 330
millions de francs ça va paraître énorme
mais pourquoi on puisse avoir une idée
de ce qui se fait ailleurs il faut
savoir quand même que c'est des budgets
qui sont un tiers de ceux qui se passe
en Italie et oui
un football il y a pas des principes
compliqués avec de l'argent de la
compétence de l'expérience on n'est pas
sûr de réussir mais déjà sans argent on
est pratiquement sûr dans le budget d'un
milliard pratiquement ah oui
pratiquement ah que ce soit le Real de
Madrid Barcelone Arsenal Manchester donc
on est vraiment tout tout petit à côté
d'eux
francs de nouveaux francs tout ça pour
ma mère de nouveau francs
c'est fou donc ce qu'on peut dire en
fait c'est
globalement le salaire grimpent et le
niveau baisse quand même
je crois que bon il y a quand même une
évidence c'est que malheureusement on
vient de gagner la Coupe du monde en 98
et le jour où il y a eu la finale à
Paris où évidemment tous les hommes
politiques de tous les bords n'avaient
pas oublié de venir voir ce match donc
je crois que après la joie
extraordinaire que cela a donné je pense
qu'il aurait quand même fallu se pencher
que les joueurs qui étaient sur la
pelouse 14 joueurs pratiquement je crois
13 ou 14 jouer à l'étranger donc là il
aurait fallu quand même se poser un
petit peu la question mais je crois que
on serait pas tellement posé où on n'a
pas voulu se la poser mais alors il y a
plein d'histoires il y a barthèse qu'il
faut savoir déjà enfin s'il le mérite
sûrement je veux pas mais il gagne un
million par mois et il a quand même pris
quatre buts le 7 avril face à l'OM et
Claude Puel qu'elle entraîneur de Monaco
a dit il a pas donné le meilleur de
lui-même et ben test tout de suite à
traduit il dit que j'étais acheté vous
voyez quand même il y a une sale
ambiance est-ce que finalement il a pas
dit ça pour casser son contrat avec
Monaco et se vendre plus cher d'ailleurs
nous on finit par penser des trucs comme
ça
on peut tout penser mais là je pense
sincèrement que on est complètement hors
sujet Barthez ce jour-là a fait match
moyen je crois que lui-même le reconnaît
il fait une saison dans l'ensemble assez
moyenne et c'est vrai que bon sur ce
match là bas
ça ce sont des dans c'est son propre
entraîneur qui le sous-entend dans moi
j'en sais rien mais moins d'argent non
non c'est vrai
je suis bien placé
que tapis revient dans le football parce
que c'est une bonne nouvelle pour
football ça bah déjà quand je serai dans
quel endroit il est à quel poste il est
je pourrais vous répondre
gracieusement il dit qu'il aurait gardé
Laurent Blanc il aurait pas fait comme
vous hein c'est bien Bernard ça sympa
sympathique attachant le seul problème
c'est que de vouloir toujours avoir
raison il se rend même pas compte des
conneries qui dit donc
[Applaudissements]
la saison dernière elle me téléphone
pour venir [ __ ] j'ai regardé le
dernier match les derniers matchs
comment tu vas faire pour continuer à
jouer avec Laurent Blanc je dis ben
écoute on va voir peut-être changer
l'organisation tout ça quand on le
transfert à l'Inter de Milan au
téléphone il dit même à l'Inter de Milan
vous avez réussi à le transférer et je
lis aujourd'hui que lui n'aurait pas
laissé par partir loin je sais même pas
s'ils sont encore des conneries
ouais peut-être prendre l'OM ça va pas
vous faire marrer ça moi je vous le dis
moi non je pense que ça serait une très
bonne chose puisque comme il y a que le
résultat qui compte les résultats
étaient là avec Bernard Tapie et donc ça
fera très plaisir aussi pour dire
Marseille bien alors on va parler un
petit peu de vous parce que vous êtes un
personnage quand même d'avoir relance
des écrits de l alors c'est votre père
quand vous déclarer à la mairie moi
c'est ce qui m'a c'est ce qui m'a
raconté donc il était initié votre père
mais le sens de l'humour parce qu'il a
dit oh bah avec deux l il faut le
rappeler autre imagine le mec t'as vous
êtes un peu torché au plastique en même
temps
il voulait parler
je suis obligé de donner des précis
alors vous étiez pas un mot vraiment
désiré parce que vos parents avaient des
problèmes d'argent il faut dire les
choses et c'est votre grand-mère qui a
dit à votre mère à la garde le petit là
tu sais pas si ça me fera d'autres de
garçons mais c'est vrai bon là ma mère
est pris rendez-vous pour se faire
avorter bon à l'époque ça se passait je
me rappelle avec la cuisine
et ma grand-mère qui était une des plus
gros croyances de la famille il y avait
dit bon mais maintenant on est un petit
peu dans la merde malgré qu'il y a un
gosse un peu moins donc on sait jamais
en plus des fois c'est le garçon et
c'était le garçon vous imaginez vous
aurez pas
alors vous grandissez au quartier de
Saint-Joseph dans le nord de Marseille
alors dans une cité castor ça je sais
pas ce que c'était les cité castors sur
on a acheté le terrain puis après on
construisait la maison avec les copains
oui c'est ce que je disais mais bon on
donnait un petit peu un coup de main à
ceux qui construisaient donc c'était à
peu près c'était un lotissement avec un
petit jardin c'était quand même
d'habitude ça a pas changé non c'est un
peu votre votre jeunesse un peu les
films de guediglian Marius et Janet tout
ça oui
que quand je regarde les films de Pagnol
ça se passe exactement dans 500 mètres
au-dessus de là où j'habitais quand vous
êtes petit évidemment au foot vous jouez
au foot le dimanche avec vos copains en
stade Vélodrome vous entrez l'OM et puis
ensuite vous jouez pro 6011 est un
espoir du foot français donc tout va
bien et là vous commencez à découvrir la
dure loi du ring si on peut dire c'est
que vous êtes échangé c'est-à-dire que
vous êtes vous y croyez vous êtes là
vous êtes prêts à donner votre vie à
l'OM et un jour vous échange à 4 c'est
un peu comme les chameaux en vous
échange à quatre contre Marius Trésor
quoi bah oui bon au départ sur un plan
affectif c'est vrai que c'était
difficile à marrer mais dans l'autre
côté comme enregistre trésor était un
des footballeurs assez exceptionnel de
sa génération le fait de pouvoir aller à
Ajaccio un échange et de pouvoir jouer
c'était finalement une bonne chose mais
c'est vrai que quand on a pas tout à
fait 19 ans comme c'était le cas c'était
vraiment très pénible de faire la valise
il parait c'est terrible quand vous avez
fait la valise pour partir le mec il
allait Ajaccio il allait pas au
Bangladesh non plus hein
de Marseille alors
après vous avez l'Ajaccio après bon vous
allez jouer au pire
limpiakos vous gagnez le transfert vous
rapporte 800000 balles que vous mettez
des gens en Suisse quand même
vous êtes un garçon très tôt très tôt
vous avez été prudent quand même pas moi
qui qu'il avait su c'était le président
du club qui m'avait fait virer ça en
Suisse et j'étais obligé 10 ans après de
justifier un petit peu le fait que
le pognon il va en Suisse bah disons que
pour être sincère j'étais parti pas pour
une question sportive j'étais parti
parce qu'il y avait une bonne affaire
financière à faire peut-être très très
tôt j'avais peut-être compris aussi que
le métier était très court que j'avais
un minimum de temps pour gagner le plus
d'argent possible donc alors non quand
vous rentrez le limpiakos on vous dit il
faut avoir un ancêtre grec pour jouer en
alors vous allez voir le mec vous dites
[ __ ] Courbis c'est grec alors le mec
il cherche par an grands-parents
c'était indispensable d'origine grecque
pour pour aller en Grèce donc avoir fait
remonter l'arbre généalogique on était
derrière grand-père il y a toujours
le tampon
et c'était tombé sur province de
Salonique et vous êtes de ça d'ailleurs
il y avait un uruguayen à Olympiakos qui
avait son grand-père aussi qui était lui
aussi bon grand-père bidon d'une
province de Salonique et lui il
racontait que les deux grands-pères
allaient draguer ensemble aller danser
ensemble et il jouait même un jeu grec
qui s'appelait le tablier à l'époque
donc on se marrait assez vous avez tout
de suite compris les murs du ballon
c'est bien alors vous jouez à ce show à
Monaco à Toulon et là à Toulon fait
trois mois de tôle pour une affaire de
fausse facture en 91
d'ailleurs en 95 j'avais coupé de trois
ans avec sursis et 300 000 francs
d'amende pourquoi bah tout simplement
parce que si on s'aperçoit par la suite
tout le monde
sait que bon vous avez pu le lire et
l'entendre c'est que bon sur le plan
fiscal on est handicapé par rapport au
pays d'à côté et nous avions trouvé une
astuce qui était la traditionnelle qui
est noir pour économiser les charges et
pareil que c'est pas beau
alors mais il y a une chose aussi non il
y a une chose aussi Thierry qu'il faut
quand même signaler c'est que par la
suite par la suite j'ai lu aussi il y a
plus de caisse noire dans le football
c'est pas qu'il y a une crise ou
d'honnêteté c'est parce que tout le
monde a peur
sinon on aurait encore des caisses
noires pour essayer de rivaliser avec
les Italiens les Anglais les Espagnols
et les Allemands alors voilà donc bon
vous rebondissez très bien vous
retrouver à Bordeaux puis ensuite à l'OM
et là vous êtes nommé par le nouveau
propriétaire qui s'appelle Robert Louis
Dreyfus donc
bon il y a eu des problèmes ou pas tout
évoqué il va faire Laurent Blanc vous
avez pas fait du bien c'est à dire que
non
c'était une connerie parce que je pense
que on a voulu dans cette affaire-là
préparer l'après le ramblant un an à
l'avance c'était très difficile aussi
d'empêcher Laurent Blanc d'aller dans un
club comme Inter avec un salaire
quadruplé la possibilité de terminer sa
carrière avec des Ronaldo very et
compagnie et donc par la suite on a été
aussi malheureux avec son remplacement
parce que tu es parti sur une idée et
notamment un argentin berizo qui est
très très bon encore aujourd'hui dans ce
retour en Argentine et malheureusement
qui est Laurent Blanc
je sais maintenant
donc voilà donc vous partez vous donnez
votre thème c'est une erreur vous vous
donnez votre DM et puis vous voilà quoi
pile engage Robert Louis Dreyfus il
engage marchand ce qui est un peu vexant
pour vous parce que vous êtes un vrai
connaisseur du football quoi
je voudrais même pas en parler je vais
vous expliquer c'est parce que vous
savez des fois l'expression on dit tel
ou telle personne pour les comparer il
boxe pas dans la même catégorie lui il
est même pas beaucoup ce que je voulais
dire
[Applaudissements]
alors dites-moi alors maintenant on
arrive aux choses sérieuses là depuis
votre départ donc on vous reproche de
comploter avec les joueurs de l'OM comme
ça de [ __ ] un peu le boxon et les
accusations étaient portées par Basile
Boli ouais bon j'aurais préféré que ça
portait par quelqu'un d'autre parce que
bon un truc a toujours été gardé secret
mais après
vous devez écrire un petit peu au moins
que Basile Boli qui a été un joueur qui
a 23 ans a gagné la Gambardella sur une
fausse identité qui ne puisse pas me
donner de leçon de morale à la limite je
veux bien prendre le son de morale je
pensais pas te parfait mais pas de
Basile bolide
c'est une coupe junior et à 23 ans on y
est plus c'est ça non non on n'est plus
on y est plus à partir de l'âge de 19
ans on parle on parle de ça parce que
c'est vrai que vous êtes l'agent de
certains joueurs non de ça aussi c'est
faux parce que on mélange tout à partir
du moment où vous avez une certaine
influence et que vous arrivez à donner
de bon conseils à jouer alors que vous
avez vous avez aussi les relations pour
aller le faire aller pour le faire aller
dans d'autres clubs étrangers je vous
donne la carrière de dugarie Dugarry
c'est un garçon qui a des qualités tout
le monde le sait et qui celle du
méchants coups de pied au mec de Calais
surtout et qui par rapport à une
certaine rencontre aura fait comme
boucle
Bordeaux Milan Milan Barcelone Barcelone
- Marseille possibilité d'aller à la
Juventus de Turin qui a été refusé par
du Gary retour à Bordeaux donc je crois
que après dire que je fais le métier
d'agent on mélange conseiller un joueur
et faire agent donc
je trouve vraiment il y a plus grave
quand même il y a l'affaire des contes
de l'OM quoi c'est à dire que la
SRPJ est en train d'enquêter vous savez
sur les relations entre l'OM et les
clubs de supporters c'est à dire que les
abonnements ensuite ils revendent
tickets par ticket
Robert Louis-Dreyfus a financé l'OM sur
sa société à lui il y a eu des
commissions versées notamment en
Amérique latine pour transférer des
joueurs vers l'OM qui n'ont jamais été
transférés il y a 3 millions de francs
sur Francisco Rojas il y a 7 millions de
francs sur un Ivoirien je crois qui
s'appelle Gaëlle
il est passé où l'argent
si moi je dois être interrogé
prochainement je le faisais non pas
encore mais je vais vous dire un truc
vous verrez par la suite pour être
inquiété il faut avoir commis des
irrégularités donc j'ai je serais pas
stupide au point disant après de
commettre les mêmes irrégularités de 10
ans avant là vraiment c'est pas avec la
police que je devrais avoir à faire
c'est avec un asile de fou
et alors bon on dit un peu quand même
que le l'OM c'est un peu quand même la
mafia que Gallardo c'est qui Gallardo
dites-le pour nos amis téléspectateurs
c'est l'un des meilleurs joueurs
sud-américains qui est le meneur de jeux
de Monaco voilà et il a été tabassé dans
le tunnel du Stade Vélodrome ce qui fait
qu'il a pas pu faire la deuxième
mi-temps et on dit que c'est des proches
de Courbis donc de vous
non non mais attendez
dans le tunnel c'est vrai inadmissible
lamentable on dit que c'est par des
proches de vous et on dit que vous êtes
un peu le parrain d'une espèce de Cosa
Nostra ouais mais avant de répondre à ma
question je vais vous dire à force
d'entendre des tailles d'état de
conneries je vais essayer de vous
expliquer la différence qui a par
exemple entre vous et moi vous voyez le
Festival de Cannes quand j'ai dit la
différence c'est pas au niveau de la
compétence c'est au niveau du personnage
que l'on veut bien fabriquer si nous
sommes sur la Croisette aujourd'hui et
que nous regardons assis à côté d'un
autre passé
et qui arrive Claudia Schiffer en
mini-jupe le décolleté moi je vais dire
[ __ ] elle est belle vous allez dire
[ __ ] elle est belle mais vous vous
êtes quelqu'un qui a bon goût moi je
suis détraqué sexuel
que je puisse me retrouver dans le
tunnel indirectement dans laquelle
Gallardo je dis oui mais c'est peut-être
même moi qui ai mis un coup de pied dans
les couilles
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ce qui m'a occasionné je pense à tort
beaucoup de jalousie et alors que bon je
trouvais ça tout à fait naturel comme je
disais des fois parce que des fois faire
un petit peu d'humour j'ai dit bon c'est
vrai que si j'avais su pour éviter ce
jalousie j'aurais pris une clocharde
pauvre moche et ben j'ai pris le
contexte
à 35 c'est vrai malheureusement c'est
une grande joueuse elle a perdu quand
même 75 millions en disant au casino
c'est vrai ça avec sa famille sur les 30
dernières années je pense que ça a dû
être même pire
bon donc vous n'êtes pas non vous avez
pas trop perdu d'argent dans un casino
avec elle et maintenant justement
j'étais ennuyé parce que j'avais gagné
donc vous avez le casino
c'est particulier le cadre casino
de 80 à 90 et il s'avère que c'est vrai
que sur cette durée là j'ai été gagnant
donc il y a un truc que je vous informe
si c'est des fois si vous avez envie d'y
aller c'est que si vous perdez vous avez
des problèmes avec votre banquier et si
vous gagnez vous avez des problèmes avec
un juge donc vous ne pouvez pas vous
vous sauver qui s'est fait interdire de
casino mais moi je ne joue plus depuis
10 ans et dernièrement pour justement
vous dire une connerie de plus je vous
jure un journal je vois que je jouais
dernièrement de la Nora non je joue plus
depuis 10 ans de temps en temps quand
j'ai le temps je vais m'amuser un petit
peu aux machines à sous pour passer le
temps mais bon là ça ça atteint pas des
grosses sommes mais sinon depuis 10 ans
je ne joue plus difficile d'être
l'entraîneur de l'OM non parce que
jusqu'à présent il y a aucun au
contraire de laine qui est resté plus
que deux saisons c'est difficile et avec
avec le recul avec le recul même si on
dit souvent qu'on dit pas de regrets
avec le recul sincèrement je serai pas
là je serai pas libre parce que je
m'aperçois que sur le plan professionnel
ça a beaucoup changé aujourd'hui je
m'aperçois que quand je suis dans un
aéroport avant me parler de football
même maintenant on me parle de l'OM et
donc m'identifier après ces 29 mois
comme je m'identifie aujourd'hui à l'OM
mais ça fait tout simplement que j'ai
pas la chaise d'avoir l'ombre d'une
proposition d'un coin français mais
après tout ce que la raconter
non oui là je réfléchis à partir et donc
j'ai essayé de retrouver mon
arrière-grand-père
bien je vais vous faire une petite
interview à peine en étant la lumière ne
bouge pas
[Musique]
qu'est-ce que vous préférez en vous
[Rires]
préférez en vous sur ces derniers temps
ma patience et la faculté de garder mon
sang
est-ce que vous détestez en vous
le fait que je fasse partie des fumeurs
[Musique]
vous saviez pas celle-là
non c'est pas le bruit
c'est comment ça que j'ai commencé ce
que vous préférez dans le ballon alors
mon métier d'entraîneur voilà
satisfaction de faire progresser un
joueur et aussi l'avoir satisfaction de
faire progresser une équipe ce que vous
détestez dans le football
on va rester dans l'actualité dans
l'actualité les incompétents
est-ce que vous préférez chez Bernard
Tapie
la
faculté de pouvoir faire pas mal de
choses ce qui est pas évident politique
football acteur chanteur animateurs télé
donc et de savoir aussi rebondir après
des épreuves vraiment peut-être très
difficile il va avoir un feuilleton sur
TF1
est-ce que vous détestez chez Bernard
Tapie mais on en parlait tout à l'heure
c'est cette illusion parce que pour moi
c'est une illusion de vouloir
systématiquement avoir raison et en
voulant avoir raison raconter après
connerie aux conneries dernière question
ce que vous avez de plus sexy en vous
relan
premièrement parce que ça m'arrange les
quelques kilos en trop que j'ai trouvé
ça sexy et je l'espère
[Rires]
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
Inna larditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu